this is root beer guy um this is a story
about a guy who is root beer and just
his everyday normal life he he works as
a telemarketer
he likes reading crime novels he is
working on a crime novel he's married
and he writes his typewriter middle of
the night write stories about what the
Sam milkshake was that it or okay there
was a milkshake I don't remember the
first name I think it was Sam but it's
something like that but yeah so this
milkshake detective and they see
something incredibly he sees Finn and
Jake kidnapping Princess Bubblegum
throwing her a trunk and driving off and
he's trying to figure out why he tells
everybody and nobody believes him so he
believes now he's kind of like in his
own crime story he's trying to put
together and he runs a narration through
his head and everyone's calling him
crazy base where sis is going on so he
follows Finn and Jake to where they're
throwing her off into this butterscotch
pond and he calls the the police pretty
much just saying that he's taking a boat
out and that get them out there even
though he told them about the kidnapping
and everything but him taking the boat
out after 8:00 that was too much so they
go out arrest him then also get Finn and
Jake and it turns out it was all just a
plan to test the security of the town
and it looks like it really sucks
because they didn't notice any event in
fact they arrested the guy that was
pointing out the kidnapping that was
going on and so they appointed the
captain of the banana police and banana
guard banana guards very shy and he
throws out this typewriter cuz he is
happy where he is now because he's
living out his dreams that he was
dreaming about him writing about um yeah
I strangely really enjoyed this I as
boring as he is intentionally boring
he's he's very likeable um he's the very
very very very very average Joe but they
still give them these little things that
make him kind of relatable like I just
love that he's into crime stories and
he's writing a crime story it's not very
good either
he's working on that one line and the
final one it's just kinda he drags it
out so long well and a lot of those
things I so many of those things that he
went through in this episode I actually
really really relate with well first of
all writing that's very true when
especially when doing humor because when
you write a line it's like man this word
SP moved around or maybe a different
we're here because it can just bomb if
it's not the right word of right
sounding word are in the right order or
bands on the right word whatever um and
so I really got that but I love how like
the final sentence he puts together it's
just so obviously not the right way and
it you did work as a telemarketer for a
very short amount of time so I
appreciated that too and and even as
he's going throw he's kind of narrating
in his head like what you know just
what's going on like it's in a story or
something I think everyone at some point
you know sort of fantasizes of you know
what if they told my story like how the
cop or something I even if it'd be
really boring yeah what's that like if
everyone is the hero of their own story
you know sort of thing um it's so I kind
of like that well um cuz I'm writing my
narration right now for my big epic
blockbuster it's gonna come out about my
life
it's gonna be incredible you're gonna be
played by Liam Neeson and jewelry is
gonna be played by incredible from The
Incredibles they're both the same oh I
don't know yeah that's funny as oh I
always ask why she looks I like like the
very basic like you know that the caper
face at the layout everything really
looks like mrs. Incredibles so I took it
from one side she like tried the flex
pay off it's like mrs. incredible is
like I didn't try I did yeah and it's
like how can that like the design of
mrs. incredible she looks incredible
this it's in the bank so okay I thought
I was giving a compliment but what do I
know
um I wasn't gonna say so no I really
liked it because I
there's something about stories where
even if the person is boring you can
still make someone interesting lead
boring and I thought they kind of did
that like if he was just a guy going
through his day and there was nothing
interesting about him you know it it
would be that it was just be boring but
because he is a writer and he does see
what's going on around him he does dream
about more and he's kind of a daydreamer
you know it's and not that that stuff is
all phenomenally unique but sort of
mixed in with the fact that he is just
kind of an average boring guy it
surprisingly makes him kind of fun to
watch and follow um and I loved Finn and
Jake pretend to be bad and how they
walked by never moving their arms at all
I thought that was very funny so and I I
just liked him being the captain of the
banana guards to I don't know why it's
like I felt good I was just like you you
go root beer guy you go oh that's like
that was awesome I enjoyed it that's
really wanted to hit him yeah you're
just really hated I just wanted to hit
him you just want oh what just to see
the glass bridge no guess like okay when
you come home and you have like that hot
piece of soda there in a maid outfit and
you're more concerned of looking at his
video problems
she's sitting there she sounds like who
let me tube the bed for you
really really dude oh wait a minute hold
on let me look at this video first
really I he should have been popping
there maybe yes maybe that's the reason
why he's boring that's because she's
consistently living in a fantasy world
obviously this is something you probably
could have written about coming home to
a wife it's all dressed up for him and
all that stuff
boom it's happening right there but no
he's really root beer guy really is is
that your major hang-up about just the
episode in general yeah
you don't like that he didn't respect
his lady enjoy his lady Thiang a hot
piece of cherry cream soda yeah would
even be hotter if she was diet cherry
cream you say hotter but you know but it
is true they're not full we're I mean
it's just half the calories you know mmm
do they you respect your woman
especially when she goes out of her way
to do something that nice for you but
there wasn't not to be fair there was a
crime going on you know people giving
murdering people in my backyard with
chainsaws and stuff and if Jory came on
the maid outfit I'd be like look look
screw that nah-nah maid outfit has to be
cherry cream soda in a maid outfit
clearly I'd be okay with that
Jory then yeah oh I like this she's like
yeah I can do that but I call her you
know mrs. incredulity like to pay hey no
cherry cream soda french maid thank you
very much no no murder who cares I'm not
a cop but I'm not a cop it's fucking
bribery you come in and kill your cherry
cream soda Jory made but that was not
happening
oh yeah but it doesn't matter this is
happening outside in your picture
scenarios that that could happen you'd
go and III die happy Oh shucks uh yeah
but but could you call the police to
have him come over and take care of the
murder as the stuff and then protect the
two of you so you can continue to have
cherry cream soda made jewelry sex why
not just get it on while it's there
because he could come in and kill you
okay but that could happen when we're
not doing anything so you know if we're
sitting there doing nothing I could be
killed I might as well be killed
enjoying is this really destroying the
episode for you is that like the one is
destroy thing a but really fucking
really yes don't disrespect your woman
man don't disrespect your significant
other even Elvis Morrell aye
going on you know while you're on the
way to the bedroom or whatever pick up
the photograph chick - dude yeah there's
a murder going outside my house yeah my
here's my address done boom done welcome
that's what he ends up doing later but
he kept following and following and
following take take okay you know what
these guys apparently haven't been
together in a while so them getting in
the sack would probably take five
minutes take five minutes on your damn
schedule of looking at your videos and
blushing she has cream soda so she would
get wet very quickly
exactly um I remain a pop of cherry
jokes I can't go there but yeah I I'm
just saying I'm just saying it wouldn't
take that long I'm guessing that that's
what um do you think he takes like the
straw and puts in the jail I like how's
it what now I'm like really thinking
about this damn it okay so actually one
thing I do want to say though that I do
love about this episode is so okay think
about it PPE
has pretty much set in motion this
entire town city village whatever you
want to call it doesn't matter if you
think about it in like an episode like
this you get to really see what's going
on she's traded pretty much all of these
citizens I have a feeling though that
they are able to get it on and actually
have kids of their own
I don't think PB is consistently making
more and more and more but I love how
there are telemarketing jobs if you look
there are parking meters hmm he's
sitting in there and he's looking at a
plane flying overhead
yeah it's like an actual working society
she has pretty much created from the
ground up an entire society why I really
liked how at the end it's like I really
thought they were gonna go in the
direction where the banana guards would
get all the praise of the group your guy
wouldn't get anything and I was gonna be
like okay I get the joke and everything
battles gonna be so angry if they went
that route I really liked it when she's
like you know well then who
how did you follow me with this guy you
know told us why is he dead cuz it's
like I really got behind her anger that
see mouse like I said it just made me
all the more happy to see him as the
captain there at thee that would have
made you mad yeah but but they didn't go
that route so it's a good episode but
that would have made you mad yeah
the I if a if the death of a person is
going on and my wife as wearing whatever
sexy outfit she has comes up I'd be like
okay dude we'll do this in a minute but
I gotta check this call somebody and
then it's up to them but this is a
pretty life okay priorities my friend
obviously so uh jory priority number one
priority number two are the kids and the
cat is your kids wanted to take care of
them more than I have to take care of
them say that so that's kinda jerk
priority number three is probably I
guess everyone else priority for I don't
know cream everything I made outfits
know that if one if it was jewelry maybe
number one now okay so Jory in so Peter
being murders like bottom of the scale
I'm a would what am I gonna do no
fucking choice
so I do dial nine-one-one and touch the
phone and just go on now that makes
sense I can see that but that means he
did I do that
no he checked the tape but okay if he
said that Colin I know why I let
somebody know it's like she would still
be upset or whatever that if you would
start to do something before getting to
her I will say oh it's as simple as this
going up to her you know putting the
tape down going to yeah give me a sec
I'll be there and now she's going
speaking for 911 phone down and go well
we all wait you would still call and say
this is what I saw whatever no but they
would come over and it's like
you still have to tell them eventually
eventually I would get around to it you
called the police
yeah and there but they okay now the one
gets to places really really fast
not really yeah no they do no no really
okay hey depending on the scenario
exactly and there is no scenario going
on here there's a kidnapping or what
nothing was said I'm saying through the
scenario of him to styling I'm not
wanted putting the phone down they would
have no idea why not on the one that's
being called sir but time is up the
effort that you know bubblegum can be
killed or whatever like at any time and
I want to get on my freak freak it's
fuckin murder what's wrong with you
murder that you know about you could
save a life you have let know you will
like the life of a politician die a
politician has created this world that
you say what's really really good that
plays flying over it telemarketers and
parking meters okay as last you weren't
very good but everything else that is
like create this incredible society you
won't let her perish because you want to
get your freak on but I'd like to also
state she wouldn't have died either way
I wouldn't be able to get my freak on
and I still would have been able to help
but you're saying she's gonna where she
gets kidnapped or something you happen
to see it and it's the real deal but
yeah I know it's a real deal by
comparison how you think I don't know
but yet so call the fucking police
coming over and you can't unless you're
doing it really well or really poorly
you can't just do it in five minutes
okay again if it's been a really long
time like it seems to have been for
these guys I don't think it's gonna take
that long dude I didn't say hate the
episode I actually like the episode I
don't like root beer guy because of that
but it's all because it's all about root
beer guy
yeah so what but the episode is actually
very well structured
it's very well written I I do love how
Finn and Jake are acted throughout the
entire thing especially where they come
to get to videotape you weren't supposed
to see this the shades yeah Jake wearing
the Hat especially the tiny tiny tiny
little yeah no I liked the episode I
don't know where you got that I didn't
like the episode I never said it good
that's all you fucking said you said no
no no the main character of this episode
because of one thing he did everything
else I was fine with okay but all you
talked about was why the punch in like I
left gaps of silence for you to continue
onto something I wanted me to continue
with it no I what I don't know it's like
you had the floor I trust you were
responsible enough to talk about the
episode instead of me
all right good plan yeah hello fair
enough
so no one to blame but you man I guess
not yeah I like it
you're fucking idiot hmm when I get my
freak on
Jory oh it's a cherry pie maid outfit oh
you kid well Shawn XD like oh wow